- Ladies and gentlemen,
it is an honor for us
to have on the show,
the infamous dictator
Benito Mussolini!
- Hi,
(applause)
- [Benito] Grazie.
- Now Benito, may
I call you Benito?
- Well my friends
call me Benito.
But none of them
are brown, so no.
(booing)
Hey!
- Oh he was joking!
(laughter and applause)
Oh my goodness when
I need good ratings,
racists are the big
hilarious, am I right?
Very funny.
Now Mr. Mussolini, I don't
mean to embarrass you,
but we have found something
very special from your past.
Take a look.
- Oh Diego, that house is
the first place I politically
persecuted someone for
being different than me.
- Aww!
Am I right, a round of applause.
He really tells it
like it is folks,
really tells it like it is.
Mr. Mussolini, let's
take a serious note.
You have been known
to say some pretty
controversial things,
some would even say,
hateful rhetoric.
- Okay, that's true.
- Now in light of that, there's
a question I must ask you
that the folks at
home deserve to know.
Is Mussolini a ticklish man?
Is he ticklish?
Should I tickle him?
May I tickle you?
- Okay.
- Okay, let's try it on.
Oh, here comes
the tickle master!
(roaring laughter)
The tickle man want to aha!
- Oh you have humanized me!
- We'll be right back,
oh tickle tickle!